[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to in two
minutes apologies for missing last week
I kind of wrecked my voice because I was
doing the Batman where is she voice
around the office a little bit too much
and I only started doing it because I
finally got to play some of Arkham
Knight and I've got to say it is shaping
up quite nicely it's if it's really fine
balance of being both quite familiar in
terms of its gameplay but it also adds
in a lot of new stuff that's making it
really fun to play so I thought I'd do
this week's episode all about the new
things we can expect in Batman Arkham
Knight and I promise to never do that
voice again ever
Batman didn't become the world's
greatest detective with just a
deerstalker and a magnifying glass a
smaller much appreciated addition to
Arkham Knight is that all of bats
high-tech kit is now a neatly organized
in a gadget wheel yes that means no more
fiddling around with the d-pad to find
the right piece of equipment in fact
missions are organized in much the same
way meaning that you won't be missing
out on anything that the huge Gotham has
to offer
we've played as Catwoman Nightwing and
Robin before but always in their own
self-contained missions now you can
switch between being the bat the cat the
Christmas bird and Nightwing made fight
with a mechanic called dual play which
is basically like playing co-op but with
yourself I found that it switched up
combat quite nicely because you can go
from Batman speedy but measured hits to
Nightwing's frenetic acrobatics with
just the push of a button or you can
slow things right down another new
mechanic is the Fiat takedown which is
similar to the breach mechanic from Call
of Duty highlight the goons that you
want to surprise and delete at the first
one after contact time will slow and you
can aim at the next attack them all and
they fall like dominoes you can upgrade
this ability with Wayne tech points to
take down yet more enemies and while
we've not seen any traditional predator
rooms in Arkham Knight just yet the Fiat
takedown is a nice nod to the
claustrophobic and stealthy gameplay of
the first game and obviously I was gonna
mention the Batmobile it's had a bit of
an overhaul since we last saw it on the
lawn of Arkham Asylum I'll be honest I
expected it to be quite sluggish given
that it's a big hulking tank
in reality it's quite zippy in pursuit
mode it punches through the environment
hammers round corners and boosts over
gaps with ease it feels like it's got
some weight to it but it's also quite
easy to control when you take it out on
Riddler's racetracks or chase fools down
the streets of Gotham things can get a
little fast and furious so if you need
extra control you can easily pop it into
battle mode which changes how it
controls and makes it more tanky and
while nothing will ever really beat the
feeling of jumping and gliding off the
top of Gotham's most famous buildings
the Batmobile is still a pretty nice way
of getting around town if you want to
see more from the Caped Crusader make
your way to GameSpot comm we have a
bunch of videos and articles all about
the world's greatest detective in the
meantime you can catch me Joe chillin on
Twitter at Lucy James games I'll see you
next time
just gonna get rid of the phlegm come on
a great day awesome one day I'll say
Twitter love today oh that's it